hey guys it's Joanna here today we're
going to tone your ass without getting
out of bed so when you're still lying in
bed refusing to get up in the morning be
sure to fit in this five minute ab
exercises this moves will strengthen
your core and the slide stretching
involved will keep you awake in the
morning
no excuses here are the workouts full
body crunch criss cross wide leg cross
sit ups leg raises and single leg pulses
each workout will last for 50 seconds
with 10 seconds of rest in between so
let's start with the first workout which
is a full-body crutch lie flat on the
bed extend entire body okay
and as you crunch up in to pass your
legs extend and Pike your legs so extend
out stretch and park your legs good job
so your legs as low as you can without
arching your back and hug your legs and
feel your lower and upper abs working
because the big is softer than your
usual yoga mat you will feel that it is
harder to work and crunch up so really
engage your core and crunch as high as
you can keep going expand stretch crunch
extend and bring your knees in and
crunch your abs good crunch expand and
crunch very good last few more one more
and just relax
second workout is criss cross so just
place your hands by your side lift both
legs up and just crisscross so you can
choose to place the upper body down on
the bed
okay and really focus on your lower abs
imagine your legs our acting like a
scissors or you can live your shoulders
off the dead and your hand off the dead
and just look straight ahead
we're going to really focus on your
lower abs and not to strain your neck on
your shoulder muscles so small movement
but you should really feel your lower
abs working keep going crisscross good
job and just breathe in and out so pace
your breathing
very good crisscross nice put breathe
out keep going few more last one and
just relax the next workout is white leg
cross punch so spread your legs stop
here in a high position okay point your
toes up as you lie down crunch up and
reach and extend the opposite side so up
and reach good down up and reach so you
should feel the stretch on your
hamstrings as well so point your toes up
and breathe out on the way up poof and
reach good job keep going
extend reach stretch out crunch and
reach good crunch and reach nice so the
slight stretching movement will also
help to improve on your flexibility
stretch nice
and keep doing as far as you can one
more and rich now lake races you can
choose to do it just on the bed or you
can choose to hold on to the edge of the
bed lower lids and bring it up
okay so simple lip razors lift your butt
up slightly and just use your arms to
support you so your arms are just
supporting you try not to pull too hard
on the bed so really lower and focus on
your lower abs keep your knees soft and
just crunch up and down good but just
slightly off the bed because it is in
the morning everything will feel tight
to get up and down nice up and down few
more keep going you should really work
and feel your low ass down up and one
more and just relax no get up please
ants by a side right leg on the bed left
wing up and I just want you to do small
pulses and bring your leg up so pointed
toes forward and you should feel the hip
flexor and your lower abs working so
just small pulses and you would really
really work and feel your little apps ok
gentle small pulses like few more and
change side straight small pulses
okay good so this would work on a hip
flexor slightly under eight legs as well
and your little ass few more keep going
this is your loss workout last few more
up up
just small houses and one more and just
relax well done so if you still refuse
to get out of bed well guess what you
can repeat the entire workout twice more
and remember that we cannot spot reduce
fat in order to burn belly fat it is a
combination of a regular car do total
body strength training core exercises
such as this workout and also eating a
well-balanced diet if you aim to stick
by your meal plan and workout plan you
should see and feel the difference in
four to six weeks all the best for new
fitness food and motivational videos
please like share and subscribe to my
youtube channel and website do you
follow me on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter to stay connected with me thanks
guys
you
you